this is an old picture that i did not
take from many years ago
it's a little complicated but i'll
quickly tell you that
it is water that is spreading out
on a surface and stopping at what we're
calling hydrophobic lines
that's what started me on my whole new
journey because that's a picture that
they made
and i said to them we could do better
and we did
this is the same phenomena where the
hydrophobic
lines are preventing the water from
blending together
that is in fact what the science is
about
this was my job to help them communicate
the science better
this is alice nasto's image of
of material that she made that she's
studying
in mechanical engineering it's a fine
image
this is the image that i made of the
identical material
i hope you see the difference if you
don't see the difference i'm in real
trouble
but basically what i'm trying to do is
engage you
to look more clearly at the research
here's an image that i got off of the
online and it's a picture of something
called ferrofluid
this is the picture that i made many
years ago
of ferrofluid that i guess people still
enjoy looking at ferrofluid
is a oil suspension of small
iron particles and when you put magnets
next to it
it it responds to the magnetic field it
for me
most of this is about getting you to see
and to first
look to engage you and to get you to
understand
that making beautiful images and honest
images which i could get to at the end
is a means of engagement which i think
is critical at this point of our lives
science in fact is everywhere
and i suggest that when you make
pictures of
everything around you it's a means of
getting you to ask
questions what is it that exactly i'm
seeing
even walking down comm ave i remember
distinctly seeing these trees for
whatever reason they were wrapped around
with cellophane
and i was looking at these assemblies
of drops around the crease everywhere
is science and why not start making
pictures of it
uh this is just more fun i i got this
device where i put my phone
on the microscope and these are just
coffee bubbles that are
kind of doing their thing in the end i
always discuss with the researchers to
maintain the scientific integrity
in your images for example when i made
this picture of
a yeast colony out of jerry thinks lab
what i decided to do was to delete
the petri dish because i
was blown away at what was going on
in this yeast yeast colony the detail
was
astounding and i wanted you to only pay
attention to that
so i deleted the petri dish the question
is was i permitted to do so
i say yes because the data
was not manipulated this is the data
not the petri dish goethe wrote
that which we know we have first seen
well let me tell you when i make
photographs
i see things that i've never seen before
obviously but i also see that it is a
means of discovery
i'm constantly asking questions whenever
i take a picture of some sort of
scientific phenomena